madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des
finances monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
vais vous donner lecture de la lettre
suivante de madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés étant
actuellement en déplacement en Irlande
j'ai demandé au ministre délégué chargé
des relations avec le Parlement Monsieur
Franck rester de vous lire cette lettre
il y a plus d'un an l'examen de ce
projet de programmation des finances
publiques a commencé de longs débats ont
eu lieu le texte a été enrichi amélioré
et vous l'avez adopté en commission en
septembre dernier cependant en première
lecture ce texte a été rejeté et nous ne
pouvons pas prendre ce risque à nouveau
en effet le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques est
un texte nécessaire il nous donne une
trajectoire budgétaire crédible pour
atteindre notre cible de 2,7 % de
déficit public d'ici 2027 une une
trajectoire nécessaire pour assurer
notre souveraineté il offre des
garanties aux Français pour la tenue de
nos engagements notamment un pas de
hausse d'impôt il permet à notre pays de
relever les grands défis à venir
notamment par des objectifs sans
précédent en faveur de la transition
écologique il assure notre crédibilité
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
et nous assurera de toucher 18 milliards
d'euros du plan de relance européenne
aussi par la présente lettre sur le
fondement de l'article 49 al à 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur le vote en
lecture définitive du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 dans sa
version considérée comme adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale en nouvelle
lecture le 30 septembre 2023 modifié par
quatre amendements adoptés au Sénat je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre l'Assemblée nationale prend
acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux dispositions de
l'article 49 aligna 3 de la Constitution
le texte sur lequel la première ministre
engage la responsabilité du gouvernement
sera inséré en annexe compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alignat 1er du règlement
le débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain 16h4 est vootter
dans les conditions prévues à l'article
49 de la Constitution dans l'hypothèse
où une motion de censure sera déposé la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et la modalité de cette discussion je
vous remercie la séance est
suspendue